[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 26 minutes pour faire
le tour de l'actualité locale et
régionale
tout de suite les titres de ce jeudi 12
avril saint quentin en yvelines a adopté
son budget et 2018 hier soir une
question au coeur des discussions
faut-il faire évoluer l'agglomération en
une communauté urbaine ce statut
permettrait de trouver des fonds
supplémentaires pour le territoire et
qui pourrait perdre et dès l'an prochain
un avantage fiscal
explications à suivre l'île de france se
dote d'une agence régionale de la
biodiversité elle a été lancée
officiellement ce matin depuis le siège
de la collectivité à 100 points
l'objectif est de protéger le patrimoine
naturel franciliens composé notamment de
dix mille espèces animales son président
et yvelinois et il est notre invité le
député modem bruno myle yens et puis
c'est une nouveauté à france miniature
elancourt les visiteurs pourront
profiter désormais des commentaires
audio de stéphane bern pour douze
monuments du parc
il était sur place hier pour présenter
cette animation après trois jours de
répit pour les usagers la grève à la
sncf reprend pour demain vendredi et
pour deux jours les cheminots continuent
leur mouvement à perler de trois mois
pour s'opposer au projet de réforme
ferroviaire du gouvernement une journée
de galère dans les transports est à
prévoir de nouveau en moyenne 2 trains
sur 5 sur l'ensemble du réseau en ile de
france pour les lignes qui concerne
saint quentin en yvelines c'est un train
sur trois pour le rer c tout comme les
lignes n et u et les horaires de vos
trains et les dernières infos sont à
consulter sur le site transilien.com
dans l'actualité politique les soutiens
à pierre bédier resserrent les rangs le
président du conseil départemental
candidat à la présidence des
républicains dans les yvelines fait face
à une contestation d'une partie de son
camp avec nous par téléphone philippe
benassaya bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
maire les républicains de bois d'arcy
également conseiller départemental et
est ce que pour vous philippe benassaya
on peut parler d'une
fronde au sein des républicains des
yvelines où finalement c'est
l'expression de voisine oles corps
qu'entendez-vous étymologiquement par
seconde
déjà les mots ont leur importance une
fronde c'est une rébellion
une france et une rébellion qui est
importante et qui exprime plusieurs
revendications
là c'est une élection interne avec un
candidat contre un autre candidat
moi j'appelle ça une démographie joue
est fait référence à cette tribune
publiée par 130 130 élus et l'eire qui
demandent justement l'organisation d'une
élection ouverte parmi ces élus il ya
pascal thévenot le maire de vélizy
villacoublay autre magnat seront
également conseiller régional je voulais
faire référence ouaya à 7 à cette
tribune je fais de vérité et que il y
avait quatre candidats
on aurait dit fils de l'autographe riz à
partir d'hier appartement il ya deux
candidats ont dit que c'est une fronde
en général lorsqu'il se passe cela à
gauche on trouve ça tout à fait normal
quand c'est à droite quand il ya du
candidat qu'il présente dans un parti on
appelle ça une fronde
donc je trouve ça que je veux je
commençais par là pour dire que ce n'est
pas une fronde c'est un combat c'est une
un dialogue qui va y avoir et c'est un
combat tout à fait démocratique et
normal
quant à la liste dont vous faites
référence est une liste de plusieurs
élus alors il n'y a pas de 138 140 comme
vous allez dis il ya très probablement
est content et j'ai regardé il ya à peu
près 90 dont 46 l'élu sur les scellés
sur les signataires et un peu près 45
élus il ya deux mers et une vingtaine ou
une trentaine de conseillers municipaux
donc il faut savoir raison garder ses
parts c'est pas une fronde
encore une fois de nerfs c'est à une
fronde une trentaine de conseillers
municipaux dont une grande partie sont
des l'isi est pas il sait pas une fronde
voyez ce que je veux dire je sais c'est
que de te répondre à votre à votre aux
mots que vous employez c'est juste 90
signataires dont une quarantaine d'élus
qui ont décidé par deux
la confiance à un candidat plutôt qu'un
autre est ce que fait anormal est en
tout cas on laisse on laisse la réponse
pour les téléspectateurs mercier
philippe benassaya d'avoir été avec nous
et on précise que dans cette élection
interne alexandra dublanche élus aux
régionales se présente également à la
présidence des républicains dans les
yvelines une élection qui devrait avoir
lieu courant octobre
faudra-t-il bientôt parler de communauté
urbaine de saint quentin en yvelines au
lieu de communauté d'agglomération la
question est désormais posée et a même
été débattu hier soir en conseil
communautaire à l'occasion du vote du
budget un changement de statut qui
permettrait de dégager une nouvelle
manne financière alors que la pression
fiscale s'accroît sur l'agglomération
elle les détails de nicolas kirillovitch
c'est un trésor de 13 millions d'euros
que doit trouver la gloire à sion de
saint quentin en yvelines
l'avantagé fiscal dont bénéficie la
collectivité pour sa participation au
système de péréquation sera remise en
cause dès l'an prochain pour trouver de
l'argent sans augmenter les impôts ou
réduire les services la majorité
réfléchit donc à évoluer et pourrait
rejoindre le club très fermé des
communautés urbaines
ça nous donnerait une bouffée d'air de
l'ordre de 8 à 9 millions d'euros par an
pour pouvoir se poser et prendre le
temps peut-être pour faire d'autres
réformes sur le long terme pour changer
de statut saint-quentin-en-yvelines
devra à nouveau s'élargir pour atteindre
le seuil de 250 mille habitants une
option que l'opposition de gauche ne
rejette pas même si pour elle un large
débat territoriale doit être rapidement
mise en place
là bas c'est une discussion d'abord
entre nous par rapport aux différentes
compétences qu'on souhaite
et aux différentes
une coopération qu'on souhaite entre nos
communes et après on verra
vers qui on se tourne cette discussion
s'est inscrit dans le vote plus large du
budget 550 millions d'euros approuvée
par les élus avec 46 voix pour et 25
abstentions un budget qualifié de
transition et d'attentes par la majorité
les délibérations pour le transfert de
compétences patine depuis plusieurs mois
on est une seule intercours avant tours
on est douze nerfs et avant de penser
peut-être à l'intercommunalité chaque
maire défend un peu sa propre ville on
n'a pas trouvé encore le rythme qu'il
faut et c'est vrai que sans ce rythme là
on a du mal à se projeter dans l'avenir
les élus ont également voté le maintien
des impôts locaux à leur taux actuel le
prochain conseil d'agglomération est
prévue le 29 mai prochain l'évolution de
l'intercommunalité devrait une nouvelle
fois à rythmer les débats najac oeil sur
ce plateau bruno milian bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le député modem de la 9e
circonscription des yvelines également
promis président de l' agence régionale
de la biodiversité en ile de france elle
a été lancée officiellement ce matin
alors avant de parler de ça deux
questions sur l'actualité politique
emmanuel macron qui était l'invitée du
13 heures de jean pierre pernaut sur tf1
pour parler de sa première année de
mandat à la présidence de la république
quel regard portez-vous sur sûr c'est un
an
moi je pense que le regard de quelqu'un
qui est très allants qui a qui a envie
de faire des réformes parce que le pays
a besoin d'être réformé
ça faisait trop longtemps qu'on était
dans l'immobilisme alors pour certains
ça peut paraître un petit peu trop
rapide on enchaîne les réformes les unes
derrière les autres mais on est obligé
on n'a pas le choix parce qu'il ya
tellement de secteurs économiques et de
secteurs de la vie française qui sont
dans l'immobilisme en panne depuis
tellement longtemps qu'il faut qu'on
aille très très vite qu'on avance pour
que les résultats se voit assez
rapidement en fait l'un des dossiers
justement c'est cette réforme à la sncf
porté par le gouvernement et qui génère
en ce moment un mouvement perlé des
cheminots on en parlait en début de
journal est ce que le gouvernement a
raison de ne pas reculer face à face aux
cheminots écoutez moi je vais être très
clair là dessus on peut ouvrir à la
concurrence sans rien changer la sncf et
je donne pas trois mois la sncf pour
survivre ouverture à la concurrence et
notamment évoqué dans ce projet
également le changement de statut de
cheminot al embauche oui juste sur
l'ouverture à la concurrence je prends
deux lignes qui nous concerne dans les
yvelines je pense que vous pouvez
demander aux usagers de la ligne j ai de
la ligne rennes s'ils n'ont pas envie
d'une ouverture à la concurrence et vous
verrez ce qu'il vous répondre alors
bruno mignonne vous êtes le premier
président de cette nouvelle structure l'
agence régionale de la biodiversité qui
a été donc lancé ce matin en compagnie
de valérie pécresse au conseil de
l'ile-de-france à sannois cette agence
est la première du genre au niveau
national une agence régionale qui est
une première du genre au niveau national
comment abordez vous ce nouveau rôle de
président alors d'abord ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que si la rb francilienne est
la première opérationnel en france c'est
parce qu'on part pas de rien on n'est
pas parti d'une feuille blanche sa part
de la part de nature nature paris voilà
un abri créée en 2007 par jean vincent
placé et on a beaucoup travaillé c'est
vrai cette année et sous la pression
d'ailleurs de valérie pécresse pour
faire aboutir le conventionnement avec
la ffb et avec des partenaires aussi
comme l'état au travers de la drieu et
l' agence de l'eau seine normandie et
donc on est dans la continuité on nous
rajoute une mission par rapport à toutes
les missions qu'on faisait déjà on nous
rajoute une mission majeure qui est une
mission d'ingénérie territoriales alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire concrètes
voilà je ne veux pas que les bureaux
d'études commencé à hurler en disant
voilà ils vont se rendre à de faire un
bureau d'études et ils vont nous piquer
notre travail c'est pas du tout ça on
veut quand on veut travailler avec les
collectivités avec les gens qui
travaillent sur des aires protégées
aussi pour travailler très en amont
notamment sur l'aménagement du
territoire de manière à ne pas faire
d'erreur vous savez qu'aujourd'hui on
parle beaucoup du réchauffement
climatique tout le monde a bien compris
l'histoire de réchauffement climatique
il faut savoir que est-ce que c'est
indissociable se réchauffe voile ainsi
indissociable versité de la préservation
et la restauration n'a de diversité ça
faut vraiment l'avoir en tête la gr
c'est à dire qu'une espèce qui disparaît
et malheureusement vous avez vu les
derniers rapports du wwf si on appuie ce
4 5 degrés d'augmentation de température
c'est 50% des espèces dans des milieux
protégés en terme de biodiversité qui
disparaissent et notamment l'île de
france 21% d'oiseaux en moins en
grillant des espèces qui sont en recul
une bonne nouvelle on a retrouvé un
castor le castor qui est de retour dans
le département voisin de l'essonne c'est
ça c'est l'objet d'ailleurs d'une
conférence ce soir
oui mais voilà il ya dressé comme ça
après il faut qu'on s'organise on peut
pas on peut pas travailler et on va
établir une stratégie pour la région on
va faire ça pour l'impro la présidente
on a travaillé dessus d'une stratégie
régionale de la biodiversité parce qu'il
n'est pas question de traiter la
biodiversité par par six lots iront
parfaire leur art et d'un côté la
métropole du grand paris de l'autre côté
le reste de la région le côté la grande
cour de l'autre côté il faut qu'il
continue t et qu'on fasse quelque chose
d'intelligent et qui servent justement
le renouveau de la biodiversité dans
notre région cette région d'île de
france justement ces dix mille espèces
animales 47 % du territoire et agricoles
280 mille hectares d'espacés boisés
c'est la région en effet la plus peuplée
la plus urbanisée de france est-ce qu'on
a tendance à oublier qu'elle est aussi
une région riche avec un patrimoine
naturel riche et c'est justement notre
chance c'est à dire qu'on a les deux
alors effectivement les zones denses en
terme d'urbanisme sont très très très
minéralisée est celle là il va falloir
qu'on les revers dix mecs n'aime pas ce
terme parce que reverdir ça veut rien
dire c'est pas simplement planté quatre
fleurs il va falloir qu'on
réintroduisent donc de la nature et de
la biodiversité dans dans les parties
très minéral il va falloir qu'on fasse
très attention
un autre aménagement du territoire pas
de mitage il faut qu'on arrête ça c'est
compliqué parce que la pression foncière
et est forte
et là on sera obligé de faire des
aménagements urbains il faudra qu'on les
pense vraiment en préservant la
biodiversité qui est tout autour mais il
ya plein d'acteurs autour de nous que ça
veut dire qu restaurer la biodiversité
c'est possible c'est pas irréversible
quand on parlait tout à l'heure des
espèces en recul
d'autres qui reviennent le castor bah
c'est pas irréversible mais il faut vous
faut qu'on arrête de faire n'importe
quoi très vite en revanche parce qu'il
ya un moment ou un autre ou
effectivement ça deviendra irréversible
alors vous comptez aussi pour mettre en
place cette agence bio de la
biodiversité sur la logique partenariale
csii aura vous en disiez des mots tout à
l'heure des partenariats avec notamment
des communes alors on a on a des
partenariats pour la création de
l'agencé je vous les citer mais on va
rester effectivement très partenariale
dans la façon de fonctionner il y aura
six collèges collège des entrepreneurs y
aura les associations dont je vais pas
tous les citer pour réguler ce serait de
manière exhaustive parce que ce serait
un petit peu embêtant pour les
téléspectateurs mais voilà je n'en
chacun de ces collèges chacun
élira un membre qui sera représenté au
directoire dont ça c'est pour la partie
on va dire administrative budget etc
en revanche sur chaque point de détail
on réunira les collèges entre deux et
quatre fois par an en fonction des
sujets sur des thématiques précises qui
fait qu'on sera pas obligé de réunir
tous les collèges mais sur chaque
thématique sur un truc pour les
entreprises on réunira les collèges
entrepreneurs on bossera avec eux on
travaillera avec eux pour être le plus
efficace possible
dernière question vous espérez que cette
première agence régionale de la
biodiversité ce que ça soit une
dynamique qui ceint sucre dans toute la
france que vous serviez d'exemple à
travers toute la france qui ait d'autres
agences régionales de biodiversité qui
se créent en france car j'ai cru
comprendre qu'on a des on allait déjà et
challenge est d'accord par la région
paca puisque il y avait la représentante
de la future aire b paca qui était qui
étaient présentes ce matin et qui nous
invitait à venir à la signature quand
ils signeront on ira avec plaisir ce
serait bien oui qu'on soit jeune junkie
peu par tout le monde parce que c'est
une saine émulation
nous on est plutôt confiant d'être une
espèce de locomotive parce qu'on a
beaucoup fait avec natureparif on est
reconnu à la fois nationalement pas
seulement régionalement et nationalement
et aussi internationalement donc donc
j'espère qu'on va être une bonne
locomotive pour les autres en tout cas
on sera ravis de travailler en
coopération avec notre chance merci à
bruno myle yens d'avoir avec nous
président de l' agence régionale de la
biodiversité en ile de france et vous
pouvez retrouver toute son actualité sur
son site internet qui s'affiche en bas
de l'écran
cette opération avait pour but aussi de
préserver préserver la propreté du
quartier et les friches à maurepas
une vingtaine d'enfants a ramassé hier
mercredi des déchets de tous genres
cadette mégot de cigarette ou encore
papiers jetés sur les dalles et espaces
verts une action pour sensibiliser à
l'amélioration du cadre de vie aurélie
ronze et patrick jacques de dixmude
après avoir été équipé ses enfants de
l'association maurepas entraide partent
à la recherche de détritus dans le
quartier les friches une opération de
propreté à l'initiative du bailleur
social toi et joie on a pas mal de
déchet notamment parfois des jets par là
par les fenêtres et donc cette action
permet de sensibiliser les enfants qui
est dès le plus jeune âge peuvent
peuvent avoir les bonnes manières et
notamment éviter de jeter un papier par
terre et plutôt allait le mettre à la à
la poubelle
[Musique]
on a trouvé des cas les plus insolites
ces deux chatons abandonnés découvert
lors de cette opération de nettoyage
ils ont rapidement trouvé des
propriétaires grâce à carolina gardienne
dans le quartier depuis une quinzaine
d'années elle fait en sorte que ce lieu
de vie soit le plus agréable possible
on a fait construire de nouveaux locaux
poubelles encombrants et om ordures
ménagères pour éviter les bacs qui était
devant et que ça donnait accès à tout le
monde en passant sur la route qu'on
pouvait tout déchet de fatou déposé chez
nous bilan de cette première opération
un des sacs bien remplis de déchets en
tous genres et des enfants sensibilisés
c'est qu'il faut pas polluer la terre ou
pas polluer la terre santé zuma présent
sur cette première en ile-de-france une
anesthésie locale pour les opérations de
la main cette nouvelle technique tout
comme le robot chirurgical dont nous
vous parlions hier est utilisé à la
clinique des franciscaines à versailles
à nous vient du canada et commence à
s'imposer peu à peu sur le territoire
reportage de camille lambert pour cette
opération du canal carpien pas de gars
ronny de paralysie du membre supérieur
comme c'est le cas habituellement
mais une anesthésie locale une technique
venue du canada adoptée par le docteur à
part depuis deux ans c'est un mélange
dans les saisies adrénaline et c'est à
dire que l'adrénaline vasoconstricteur
vaisseaux et les rapts hisse donc en
fait ça évite le saignement
saisi toute la zone opératoire et même
si cette patiente est sous
anticoagulants c'est-à-dire un
médicaments qui fluidifient le sang et
bien l'adrénaline joue son rôle de vaso
constricteur ça ça vient pas pendant
l'intervention comme vous avez vu et
elle a pu se servir aussitôt de sa main
et sortir avec un petit pansement pas de
garos pas de sédatifs elle est pas à
jeun c'est un peu comme chez le dentiste
finalement si l'anesthésique goualante
existe depuis 15 ans en amérique du nord
c'est une nouveauté sur notre territoire
la clinique des franciscaines à
versailles et la première en ile de
france à proposer cette technique et à
la faire découvrir aux chirurgiens
j'avais pas vraiment cette habitude là
on avait ça fait six mois que je fais
que ça pour la main et où je vois
vraiment le changement c'est nous qu'ils
auraient saisi
donc on suit le patient du début à la
fin donc il est vraiment en confiance il
n'a pas quarante personnes différentes
qui va voir au bloc opératoire
une confiance qui se confirme à la fin
de l'intervention
cette patiente joue du piano et
craignait de perdre certaines facultés
mais c'est génial
la première chose que j'ai faite après
l'opération j'ai regardé si je pouvais
jouer
bon ben je peux jouer au c'est génial de
toute façon je reviens dans un mois pour
faire la main gauche qui est sur les
nerfs mais aussi prothèses de pouce aux
opérations osseuse
la technique se développe pour permettre
de plus en plus d'interventions sur la
main et commencent également être
utilisé en chirurgie du pied
c'est la grande nouveauté cette année à
france miniature les visiteurs pourront
entendre la voix de stéphane bern
l'animateur de télévision et de radio a
enregistré ses commentaires sur ces
douze monuments préféré visible au parc
en format réduit
pour présenter ce projet stéphane bern
était sur place hier elle en cours tout
comme michael et demi d'euros ce château
présente la gloire de celui qu'on
appellera longtemps le plus grand roi du
monde
vous avez sans doute reconnu sa voix
france miniature accueille cette année
un monument de la télévision stéphane
bern
l'animateur a enregistré des
commentaires audio sur 12 sites
historiques français avec au programme
des anecdotes une vraie passion pour
monsieur patrimoine sur un site à l
encours vous avez un ensemble de tous
les joyaux de la france et je trouve que
c'est une mise en valeur du patrimoine
pour les générations qui viennent et on
est dans le lent vie de transmettre aux
jeunes générations
je me dis mais si ça peut éveiller le
goût de des visiteurs et leur donner
envie d'aller voir en vrai sur place
j'aurai réussi mon pari
via des bornes interactives stéphane
bern propose un tour de france du
château de chambord en passant par
l'hôtel des invalides à paris
avec ce partenariat france miniature
espère booster sa fréquentation et vise
le chiffre de 200 mille visiteurs sur
cette saison 2018
stéphane bern est un moteur je pense que
ça peut intéresser nombre de visiteurs
et puis surtout ça permet d'ouvrir la
culture et l'histoire à des nouveaux
visiteurs et d'apporter à
par un nouveau billet un nouveau canal
et de séduire d'autres types de
populations je pense aux enfants
notamment qui le suivent à la télévision
et qui pourront le retrouver sur le
temps la voix de stéphane bern sera à
découvrir dès le samedi 14 avril à
france miniature de religion aller avant
de se quitter la flûte enchantée c'est
sans doute l'opéra de mozart le plus
connu composé en autriche en 1791 cette
oeuvre ne cesse d'inspirer à la ferme de
bel ébat de guyancourt c'est le cabinet
vétérinaire qu'ils interprètent ce
samedi avec 14 avril une adaptation
pétillante et miniatures mélanie poker
et marion ptac ont rencontré edouard
signolet qui signe la mise en scène
regarder et devant signalé bonjour
bonjour alors votre flûte enchantée et
une miniature mais miniature par le
nombre d'artistes sur scène une
comédienne quatre chanteurs et un
accordéon enfin c'est tout à fait ça
comment on en vient à faire la flûte
enchantée
comment on en vient sur cette forme là
sur cette forme là on en vient parce
qu'on a envie enfin en tout cas moi j'ai
envie de faire partager d'opéra au plus
grand nombre
quand on pense au peyrat on pense gros
décor énorme choristes fosse d'orchestre
énorme donc un temps de travail énorme
et du coup surtout sur des lieux
spécifiques ce qui fait que l'opéra se
trimballe pas partout fins ne transporte
pas partout et donc l'objet en fait de
cette miniature lyrique c'est de pouvoir
jouer partout et ce qui était fascinant
sur le travail qu'on a élaboré c'est
qu'on peut jouer vraiment partout dans
la rue dans des théâtres dans des lieux
qui sont pas forcément théâtraux on la
joue dans des lycées voilà dans dans les
salles est on vraiment on sait apporter
l'art lyrique partout le format est un
peu plus court parce que l'original fait
près de trois heures vous voulez
réduisez à 50 minutes
c'est aussi pour amener plus de
personnes vers l'opéra exactement en
fait c'est pour en fait comme l'opéra
fait souvent peur notamment par sa durée
non là vraiment réduit sur les plus
grands airs en tout cas on a sélectionné
les plus grands airs à l'orchestré
d'accordéons pour vraiment que ce soit
on va dire entre guillemets plus plus
digeste en fait et ça fasse moins peur
voilà le format 3 heures peut souvent
faire perdre mon dieu je vais pas tenir
alors que bon en général on se laisse
quand même on peut respirer leurs tracts
quand même mais là ici c'est vrai que
c'est un spectacle complet sur une heure
et c'est vraiment une sorte aussi de
sensibilisation à l'opéra c'est vraiment
l'envié en fait qu'on a eu avec mon
équipe de vouloir
taj est une autre passion de l'opéra à
tout le monde ce qui fait que vous
l'ouvrez des six ans oui tout à fait un
format qui permet avec la comédienne qui
justement explique que c'est d'amener
l'enfant
oui tout à fait et après c'est aussi une
autre crainte comme l'opéra est souvent
dans une langue étrangère que ce soit
l'allemand l'italien et même quand on
chante tout et pas toujours extrêmement
clair là ici le format c'est vraiment de
revenir aux comptes comme la flûte
enchantée c'est un conte la comédienne
raconte toute l'histoire notamment
l'histoire qui est chanté pour que tout
le monde puisse vraiment rentré dans
l'oeuvre même si c'est chanté en
allemand à la flûte enchantée c'est
quand même l'un des plus célèbres de
mozart et son dernier justement est-ce
que ça a été un frein dans l'adaptation
ou au contraire vous y comme tout le
monde le connaît on peut prendre un peu
plus de liberté en fait c'est comme tous
les grands classiques comme tout le
monde les a un petit peu dans l'oreille
on peut vraiment s'amuser en fait à un
peu dévié l'oeuvre
c'est vraiment c'est pour ça que la
parodie c'est pas vraiment une petite
parodie sans est une parodie
enfin notre forme et elle a en fait ce
qui est intéressant c'est comme tout le
monde la connaît un peu c'est toujours
intéressant de dévier sur les grands
classiques
en fait on part on dit toujours ce qui
est très connu est-ce qu'on retrouve les
grands airs notamment celui de de la
reine de la nuit que je ne chanterai pas
tu pourrais parler les oreilles de nos
téléspectateurs justement parce que
c'est aussi des morceaux très célèbre
bien sûr on a on a cet air là et on a
tous les autres grands tubes celui de
pamina car de la tristesse et puis bien
sûr l'ère de la fureur de la reine de la
nuit
all away papageno et papagena aussi
voilà c'est sur scène des chanteurs
lyriques tout à fait quatre ans de très
grands chanteurs
[Musique]
qui
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'aussi c'était le but c'était de
d'avoir aussi une très grande qualité
musicale et donc on a quatre chanteurs
d'exception
un accordéoniste super accordéoniste
voit la super comédienne aussi et donc
c'était vraiment garder l'exigence
musicale
c'est à dire c'est pas parce que c'était
un spectacle jeune public qu'il fallait
relier sur l'exigence musicale nous
parler du compte alors est-ce qu'on suit
toujours les aventures du prince tamino
c'est bien lui tout à fait c'est bien
lui il est là du début à la fin et que
céline prend en charge et donc elle
prend en charge aussi tous les autres
personnages
et comme on a aussi inclus les coeurs on
a fait l'adaptation des coeurs avec eux
les les quatre solistes sont les quatre
chanteurs et donc on avait aussi des
morceaux de coeur à l'intérieur parce
que comme on a quatre chanteurs on a à
peu près le spectre de toutes les voies
fin de la soprano jusqu'au baryton ce
qui fait qu'on pouvait donner des
couleurs d'ensemble et de coeur si on le
voit derrière nous la mise en scène est
minimal c'est totalement injuste pour
rentrer dans la voie à l'ecoute alors il
ya deux choses en fait pour moi c'est
faire croire au spectateur compte dans
un concert classique typique qui à un
moment par totalement sucette
en fait on dévie vraiment le concert
classique qui est ça devient un
spectacle on commence par un concert et
ça devient un spectacle et aussi le fait
que ça soit totalement minimaliste tout
laisser toute la place à la musique mais
aussi à l'imaginaire en fait ce qui
fonctionne le mieux
enfin en tout cas dans ce qu'on a pu
remarquer avec les enfants c'est que
tout ce qui n'est pas tout ce qui est
dit et raconté
eux ils l'imaginent en fait comme on le
donne pas avoir eu il imagine tout ce
qui se passe en fait les dragons le
château et on remarque souvent ça avec
les enfants après le spectacle en fait
ils nous donnent des dessins de tous
qu'il n'y avait pas en fait et ça c'est
toujours surprenant pour nous parce
qu'il n'y a rien sur le plateau mais
dessine toujours les chanteurs et plein
de choses autour en fait on voit
vraiment qu'il rentre dans l'histoire
complètement ça marche aussi sur les
adultes parce qu'ils sont vraiment les
acteurs donc c'est vraiment à un décor
sonore humain voilà et c'est un
spectacle qui évolue alors il a évolué
tout à fait parce que la première fois
on l'a créé c'était donc à la
philharmonie de tarifs
anciennement cité de la musique c'était
sur un format très très court de 12
minutes
donc il y avait que deux chanteurs et à
chaque fois qu'on a repris le spectacle
on la recréer un tout petit peu on a
allongé les airs on a rajouté faire moi
j'ai rajouté un chanteur
et à chaque fois on a fait grossir la
forme donc à chaque fois ce spectacle a
toujours évolué merci et devoirs signalé
alors la flûte enchantée du cabinet
vétérinaire est à découvrir samedi 14
avril à la ferme de bel ébat de
guyancourt et premières notes à 20h30
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal cette
information importante à vous rappeler à
demain reprise de la grève à la sncf et
pour deux jours pour les lignes qui
concerne saint quentin en yvelines et
prévoir un train sur trois pour le rer c
tout comme lé ligne n ai eu les horaires
de vos trains sont à consulter sur le
site transilien.com cette édition est à
revoir sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile la tv 78 et demain
vendredi place aux 7,8 l'hebdo présenté
par nicolas kirillovitch et toutes les
idées de sorties sur le territoire à
retrouver également dans le satuc
loisirs de camille lambert nous on se
retrouve lundi pour un nouveau 7,8
journal
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]